الى روسيا
يمكنها ان توقف هذا العدوان اذا اردت ذلك
لكن يمكننا ان نسرع من انتصارنا
وهذا سيؤكد لكل معتدي بانه لا يمكن لاي
طرف ان
يقترف اعمال شنيعه
وان يفرث من العقبه
فاعتقد بانه
علينا
معرفه
البلد
وبيئتل فنحن بحاجه الى سلام نعم اوكرانيا
قد اقترحت السلام سبق لها انفعل ذلك كما
قلت ذلك مع السيد بايده
الحال هناك بعض الاشياء التي يجب ان
نضمنها
العقد المقبل وانني سعيد عيد اعلم بان
الرئيس بيضا قد دعم مبادره اتجاه السلام
اليوم يمكنكم ان انتم همم
تتاكدوا
من
اننا نعمل ان نتلاقى من بطريقه
[تصفيق]
مشتركه
يمكنكم ان تعززوا العقوبات حتى تشعر روسيا
بان اهو مواصله هذا الحرب
ستدمرهم ايضا
اعتقد بانه علينا ان نجعل اولئك المجرمين
يتحملون هذه
المسؤوليتهم وان يعاقب الارهابيين
[تصفيق]